oh my goodness gracious River babes
we've made it to the season 3 finale
once again I'm your host Liana Clara and
this is your live Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode 322 chapter 57
survive the night which sounds oh so
dramatic and trust me it is now today
I'll be giving you my three clues about
the finale and once again we'll be doing
a live Q&A so start sending me your
questions and comments because this is
the last time we'll be doing this I
already see so many of your comments
coming in and it makes me so happy but
first you know what you River babes left
more than a thousand comments on our
last Sweetwater after-show for episode
321 and here are just a few of my
favorites of your kisses and kisses
first off Lauren Olivia posted kisses to
Archie for stating the obvious
yeah Ronnie your dad sucks yes I loved
this line and I was also very flattered
with the fact that you all gave a lot of
kisses to me from my line calling it the
Magic School Bus from hell and all of my
other savage quips from the last episode
it always makes me very happy to see
that I'm making you all laugh so thank
you for the sweet notes and the crying /
laughing face emojis moving on anonymous
Sophie wrote kisses to my baby Sheryl
saving her love Tony from the farm it
reminds me of when Tony saved Cheryl
from the sisters of quiet mercy oh yes
you guys such a classic season 2 scene
and a callback to a time when things
were only mildly crazy yeah next up
trinity Hopson is also weighing in on
the romance of it all and saying hisses
- this whole veggie ship like stop
breaking Archie's heart Veronica yeah
okay I will agree that this whole barchi
veggie yo-yoing thing is getting pretty
tedious also when I was in high school
no one had these Ultra romantic love
triangles you went to the movies with
like a group of friends and then you
awkwardly told your crush that you
thought they were
cute only if they thought that you were
also cute is this anyone else okay
meanwhile unique Karen eek knows what
I'm saying she commented remember when
the scariest thing in Riverdale was
Jughead joining the serpent's now it's a
40-something year old guy stealing
organs from teens and forcing them to
join a cult exactly the stakes are
getting higher and higher and it makes
me wonder if we can ever reel Riverdale
back to the simple season 1 s times when
these teens aren't being butchered and
speaking of twiggy serial killers
Ellie's edits added I refuse to believe
that Jason is The Gargoyle King same and
it seems like Theon Egan has a new
theory about this because they wrote I
think that Jason was born with the twin
brother and was swapped with Cheryl and
the sisters of quiet mercy and the real
Jason blossom was killed
and now his twin is coming for revenge
hmm well we know that Riverdale loves a
good twins swap storylines so this isn't
too far-fetched so I'll give you a
credit there but meanwhile Zoe Cahill
weighed in writing plot twist
Jason just wants his jacket back that
one made me laugh Thank You Zoe
and lastly reading k10 chimed in with
this gem of a theory
it's definitely chick with red hair and
no one will tell me otherwise Jason is
one of the only dead people we've
actually seen dead you don't get more
dead than a bullet through the head
found in Sweetwater River most of the
cast has said how the show isn't going
supernatural and I trust them yep
I totally agree with this it's gotta be
chick and you know who else you can
trust me and you know who I trust my
friend and fellow River babe and et
correspondent Katie Krauss now she
caught up with actor Hart Denton and
pressed him for answers about chicks
return way back in February and here's
what he told her I'm good welcome to the
Teen Vogue young Hollywood parties
I'm gonna jump right into the Riverdale
of it although when is chick coming back
you daddy is coming back I don't know
what I can and can't say cuz the show so
secretive so I don't want to give
anything away I think that publicly
there have been some comments by
different people really wanting me back
and saying that I was coming back and
will say do you don't think this is long
term do you don't know what do you think
happened to chick when he was left
running from the black hood I think he's
been training a lot he's been honing in
on his defense goes because someone was
trying to kill him what if she comes
back I wouldn't mess with him
number one he's target number do we feel
like Archie and chick are gonna have a
bromance keep teasing a bromance over
here maybe on Riverdale I've drawn some
muscles yeah let's do it my problem you
think that chick has anything to do with
a gargoyle King I think you can't count
check out of anything I think that's the
best part about chick is you think you
got him for a second then you're like
what's happening boundaries are key
they'll keep you alive what do you think
about Chad Michael Murray joining the
show love Chad Michael Murray yeah so I
learnt to work with him oh no
if chick were to come back soon do you
feel like he wants revenge on anybody as
we saw last season I think he holds on
to things you know maybe I should call
the police tell them what sort of things
my sister's capable of doing she
wouldn't dare I think he wants to be
good I've said that from the beginning
he wants to be good he really does this
side of him maybe did he come back
should he come back I think so I think I
loved watching Hart squirm and kudos to
Katie Krause for pressing him for so
many answers great job girl
now what do you guys think there's only
one episode left so now we're never
chick now while you guys keep commenting
with your chip-tastic thoughts let's
take another look at the promo for the
season 3 finale chapter 57 survived the
night the invitations say not to tell
anyone
so it's a trap I will kill you and your
friends we're getting out of this house
of the devil that's suicide I refuse
the Ascension is upon us you're nuts
[Music]
the hunt is a thought what now that's a
trailer it has it all ball gowns sweet
baby Kevin a whole lot of death
implications an iconic Cheryl blossoms
scream and most importantly naina
freaking rose mm-hmm
now if you're not already pumped then
get ready for a dose of adrenaline
because it's time for my three clues
number one this episode may be called
survive the night but I'm renaming it
the twisted trifecta of evil number two
they say dead men tell no tales but what
about delusional men instead and number
three just when you think it's all
sunshine and milkshakes get ready for a
bloody surprise and also I have exciting
news for you river babes
once you finish watching Riverdale head
over to et online or my Twitter page to
read my exclusive article with Roberto
aguirre-sacasa because he's answering 11
of the biggest questions you will have
after the finale I'm not kidding you can
watch it right away or you can read it
right away before you watch the
after-show tomorrow okay because in our
Sweetwater secrets after-show star
Camila Mendez is spilling the milkshake
on the scene that everyone will be
talking about so you don't want to miss
it but now let's shift over into our
last live Q&A session of the season oh
so glad you guys are all here okay so
starting us off Jan said I think Polly
is going to die in this episode wouldn't
that be lovely I mean of course I don't
want to wish death on anyone but Polly
sucks so good riddance
Dede says if Paul II dies I will feel
sad for her babies no dad no mom tough
life this is true this is true Jennifer
and Dagwood but should we should already
be concerned for those babies because
they have been the size of like three
months old for like a two years now or
something so we should maybe look into
that heather since when is there ever
happy ending on Riverdale you know what
they're gonna make you think that there
is one but then there isn't because it's
Riverdale John of the Dead hisses - the
whole veggie thing coming out of nowhere
yeah I I wouldn't say it's coming out of
nowhere but it does feel like we've been
toyed with this whole time like dangling
in front of us just as we are getting to
like them and know them they ripped it
apart and then they forced it back
together I don't know it just feels
weird love Charles Melton and cami
Mendes being together in real life so
cute but um not so much their characters
Alaska says are we gonna get a romantic
bug-head scene like we normally do at
the end of the season and apparently
everyone wants bug heads and hints about
the finale this finale you guys is and
this is the first thing that I said to
Roberto when I talked to him on the
phone it's unlike any other episode
we've seen on Riverdale and that's
saying something because we've seen a
lot so everyone is very preoccupied with
what they have to do in this episode
each couple does get a time to shine
they're small but they're sweet so take
that what you will we know that this has
not been the most romantic season of
Riverdale I feel you guys but they did
try and give everyone a little
something-something
okay let's see
Ruby Burrell is Sweet Pea here in this
episode we haven't seen Sweet Pea in a
couple of episodes so I'm just gonna
leave it at that if no sorry no amazing
hair wrote hisses - Edgar for being so
damn complicated oh my goodness yes one
of the things that I will choose to you
is when I did talk on the phone through
Berto I asked him hey we saw a really
dark twist with the farm and finding out
that they were harvesting the organs was
this the plan from the very beginning so
you'll have to read my article to find
out what his answer was but I was really
shocked by his answer so just like
you'll be shocked by a lot of things in
tonight's episode but I always like to
ask Roberto when they came up with these
twists was it from the beginning or did
they figure it out along the way because
I think it's really satisfying as a fan
to know
if this was always part of their master
plan and I feel like we can usually tell
and it's just nice to have that
confirmation so I'm asking all the
questions and I know that you guys would
be too so I've got you um ASAP rush says
why would the black hood go for Betty
when she helped him that is a great
question
why would the black hood keep chasing
after his own daughter we see in the
trailer that the black hood looks like
it's hell so honestly I have no idea
anymore other than the fact that it's a
Down
jazzy Jones I'm oh boy I'm nervous about
that last clue you should be you should
be nervous
Halina what's happening with Shoni well
when we last saw Cheryl sacrificed
herself so that Tony could escape from
the sisters of quiet mercy that is now
the farm that is harvesting organs and
Cheryl fought off a bunch of guys and so
that her love could escape and run into
the woods wearing only a ball gown or
not a ball gown a hospital gown so as we
as we know they are apart could there be
a reunion I would hope so
but we will find out we do get Nana rose
though so think the Riverdale gods for
that kiona says you said that Hiram had
a big role in the finale and that will
make your eyes roll what can you tease
about that I did say that at the time I
was under the impression that the Hyrum
fight against Archie was in the finale
he still does pop up in the finale
though and once again it will make your
eyes roll so Olivia says idk whether
Jason is The Gargoyle King as a lot of
people are saying it's chick oh sorry
thanks for you go
sorry guys once again my hair is going
rogue as far as the gargoyle King let's
talk about this we've had so many fake
outs at this point it was Clifford
blossom it was tall boy it's now Jason I
did not know that we could have so many
reveals that turned out to be fake so at
this point it's one episode to go you'll
get the reveal does it does it matter as
much anymore I'm not sure that's up for
you to decide because I personally felt
like since we've had so many fake outs
at this point I'm just like let's just
get it over with
but at least it'll all be done soon Mike
says so will the original and current
gargoyle King be revealed tonight maybe
Roy K says kisses to Betty for being so
determined once again yes kisses to
Betty for everything kiss away Betty you
deserve kisses Lauren does Josie get a
proper goodbye
that was her goodbye you guys um when
when she skipped town from Riverdale she
didn't even get to make it to prom that
was Ashley Marie's last Riverdale
episode but like we said last week
everyone give her love because the
Riverdale spin-off Katie Keene has been
picked up so yay Ashley will get to see
her on our screens soon and then I hope
that Josie will get the time to shine
that she deserves here we go Olivia is
it just me or do you think that in the
last episode when Toni escapes the farm
Cheryl could have escaped too instead of
saying a speech okay that's funny I
think that it was good that Cheryl
sacrificed herself for Toni because it
was actually Cheryl's it was it was not
Cheryl's fault that Toni got into the
farm but because Cheryl was in the farm
she pulled Toni in so I thought it was
really great that Cheryl put herself in
harm's way so that Tony could get out
and be safe could they both have made it
probably they seemed very fast and fit
and I don't think those big hulking
Hospital guys would have been able to
fit through that tiny window but you
know what romance it's all for romance
sunshine asks any surprising arrivals in
the finale
there are surprising scenes and now I
guess you could say surprising arrivals
I guess you could say but I've already
filled you in on my theory you guys have
all all guessed it already so I think
we're we are bug head level detectives
at this point I'm very proud of all of
us great job guys
we're gonna just take a couple more
actually we're doing good on time so
we're gonna let this go because this is
our Q&A our last Q&A of the season you
guys spends our kisses to Shoni being
the most caring
couple I don't know if they're the most
caring couple but they definitely care a
lot for each other and it's been really
nice to see the evolution of them this
season and somebody else asked me
another question and I'm trying to
figure out where it went and it was
about my favorite couple let's see let's
see let's see
Oh Caitlyn says what are three things
you personally want to see next season
that is a great question Caitlyn okay
and then we'll go to Carlotta okay three
things that I personally want to see you
next season I would love to see our
couples go on dates and not be nearly
murdered as weird as that sounds I would
love to see just like a simple going to
the movies and like yes there's gonna be
issues because it's Riverdale and they
won't give us like a pure happy episode
but like I would love to just see a
wholesome highschool episode like
freaking out about a test or or who's
gonna be the head of the Vixens or
something I don't know I don't know if
we can ever get back to that point but I
missed that simpler high school time and
that is gonna be addressed a little bit
and the fact that Riverdale has gone so
far off the rails you'll see the
characters really have that nice meta
moment but so that's one thing I would
love I would love to see us return to
that I would love to see less of higher
and lodge and that is no offense to
marken suelillis he's a sensational
actor but the fact that they constantly
just rely on him to keep being the big
bad I can't anymore and then the third
thing that I would like to see is for
Kevin to have a proper storyline I've
harped on this every single episode at
this point sweet baby kevin is always
cast to the side he's a glorified extra
at this point and when you had Casey
caught an actor who was so talented so
kind so dynamic on screen why would you
not write to him in for him and and let
his strengths shine so that's for me now
Carlotta had said to me and I wasn't
gonna answer this question but I figured
it's the last episode she says I know
you shouldn't compare them but Leanne
who is your favorite couple on the show
now as I've told you guys all the time I
support your right to ship whoever you
want and if you're a fan of that couple
then I take it upon myself to ask the
couple were to ask the cast about those
couples so for all those barchi fans
when they wanted some scoop I made sure
I deliver it I got some Veggie I got all
these different things and I know as
people say like you're not supposed to
be biased and you're not supposed to
have a favorite ship I'm sorry I'm human
I adore bug-head I love their evolution
I love the fact that you know the Archie
comics were all about Betty Veronica and
Archie and that love triangle and I love
the fact that Riverdale did something
different and really introduced us to
this relationship that we've been able
to see grow and blossom and I've really
been a big fan of that and I love their
dynamic together and it doesn't hurt
that Lilly and Cole had great chemistry
together as well so that's just nice
I loved the introduction of Sheryl and
Tony's relationship and I think that it
was so great to see them give Sheryl
some love and some happiness and I think
Tony topaz is one of the most underrated
characters on the show yes we want that
backstory and then in terms of Veronica
and Archie I love them I think they're
great
this yo-yoing back and forth between
them made my love for them dim just a
little bit but I do think that they're
great but if I hear the word end game
one more time I'm gonna lose it okay
Kyra says I think chick is The Gargoyle
King and dug up Jason's grave to make it
look like it's Jason the whole grave
situation was just really morbid don't
you guys agree that was weird
star Tony needs a backstory yes we can
all preach we've all been screaming it
they hear us
Emma leave Archie and bug head double
date yes I would love of Archie and bug
head double date I also want Shoni in
there to let them let them go and do
something and then I don't know Kevin
can find a love who doesn't let's go
through Kevin's love life shall we
he was with Joaquin who got all caught
up in the Griffons and gargoyles of it
all and then died and then he's with
fangs and fangs got deep into the farm
and you see in that trailer promo that
Kevin looks all alone and sad so I'll
let you try and come to your own
conclusions but poor Kevin
milah Vermilya kisses to the cast crew
and writers and extras who've worked so
hard the season and kisses to Lana and
your crew for working so hard and making
us happy from Sweetwater secrets love
them all Oh Miley if that was very kind
of you
um that makes me so happy I'm gonna be
saying like a more proper goodbye in our
after show but yes thank you so much to
all you river babes who have been
watching these past two seasons that
we've done Sweetwater secrets I've
expressed to you before that it takes a
lot for me to whip up two episodes of
sweet water for you each and every week
goodness gracious but my crew is
sensational and they're always here for
me when I run in at the last minute to
say hi to you guys and Hank my editor is
just so sensational I can't even put
that into words but you guys are the
best because you have been so sweet so
kind so positive in our comment sections
so thank you so much and you also were
so sweet a couple wholly lost it over
Luke and I'm so embarrassed about that
but you guys made me feel so great so I
wanted to take an extra thank you for
you right now okay just a couple more
kate says is there any hint of FP
helping save Alice from the farm
I mean kisses because she went so far
off her rocker but we'll OH but we'll
live a long connection oh but will a
lifelong connection help bring her back
Alice is an interesting mother and
that's all I'll say that's all I'll say
Liana kisses to Roberto for all the plot
twists I love it I love it too it's been
it's been a it's been a whirlwind of a
season and you'll see all of Roberto's
answers in my article and I think that
it'll help you guys really make some
sense of it all okay let me just go and
check it back up Lexi is this gonna
clear up the whole farm mystery - not
sure about that
Miley also said love your dress Liana
complements you thank you guys I didn't
know which character to emulate today
and I didn't have a ballgown at least
not one that was handy so I wanted to
match the set and and be a source of
sunshine and happiness for you guys for
our last episode and I think we're gonna
leave it right
there now thank you guys so much we're
tuning in to our last live Sweetwater
preview and be sure to check my Twitter
page after you've watched the finale so
you can read my article with Roberto
aguirre-sacasa and then you'll press
play on our Sweetwater after-show to see
what kami had to tell me about season
four hmm now comment below with your
predictions for the season three finale
give this video like all that great jazz
and I'll see you for one more episode
Ripper babes
[Music]
you